lack of your excuses and they'll use the
insight to excuse them from taking a
leap money is just not attracted to
excuse it
what's that believe nation it's Evan I
believe in you and this channel is
designed to be a part of your daily
success routine so today we're gonna
learn one of the most common rules that
successful people follow stop making
excuses also if you want to know what
Gary Vee Mel Robbins Grant Cardone and
others have to say about building
unstoppable confidence check out my 2:54
confidence series where every day for
the next 254 days I will send you a
morning video for free to help you build
your confidence the link to join is in
the description below the reason people
aren't patient is they value other
people's opinions too much I know that
everybody's problem comes down to one
pattern you're repeating that you can't
see you have to go build self-confidence
[Music]
and this is my biggest point to
everybody this is why I don't allow
complaining or yelling and for people
that want to with me because no matter
what I'm gonna point to somebody who had
the same exact sit Oh what you had a
crackhead father and your and your mom
you sexually abused you and you got
stabbed cool let me show you this kid
who actually had that exact same thing
and he won that what we're talking about
right now is the reason I win I'm not
worried about the little details this is
all macro blueprint strategy mental
strategy no matter what we say right now
P I'm gonna show you somebody who grew
up with the same exact situation have
different outcomes and so for me
everybody he's dwelling on their
shortcoming the bottom line is no matter
where you start
everybody has paths to winning and
losing for me the best move is to take
control your no matter how tough you are
right now get rid of loser friends and
family introduce yourself to positivity
and winners and watch how it plays out
to many of you're sitting around waiting
to feel ready you can still move forward
when you're not ready too many of you
are waiting to feel like you deserve to
make six figures it's about the action
your mind your history your past you
will always have a million excuses not
to do it not to feel like it not to
believe in yourself they're all the only
thing that matters in your life and your
business is the actions that you're
taking and the more consistently
you take action the faster you will
start to believe in yourself because you
will see proof that you are not the kind
of person that sits around and feels
unworthy that you're not a victim that
sits by and get sucked into other
people's stuff that you're not that kind
of person so it won't make sense to
believe it anymore but it starts with
action I believe in all of you and I
believe in your ability to get it done
but it's going to be up to you who is
the problem yeah who's the solution
that's right don't need to feel like
that it's the biggest mistake you could
possibly make it remember that you're
smart remember that you know what to do
and just get it done was the greatest
lesson your mom taught you growing up
honestly the greatest lesson sheera
taught me is the lesson that she did she
doesn't know how much she taught me
because she wasn't much in the teaching
mode my dad took her soul but what I did
as a young kid is observed everybody I
wasn't really smart in the books yeah if
I was real smart when it came to life
yeah and I was able to sit back and
watch her mistakes I was able to see how
she struggled through life and how I
don't want to struggle through life and
I was able to see she never picked me up
the biggest thing she did for me and
this is honest-to-god truth and she
doesn't know she did it without I bust
my ass but I would fail you know when I
was at the bottom of the sewer she never
picked me up she never gave me that
cookie and said hey son you know she'll
be okay so no she didn't have time for
that and sometimes she gets upset when I
talk about my past because if it paints
her out to be not the best mom if I had
any kind of mom in that kind of
environment I would have never made mmm
because she forced me for ever reason
she forced me did you better figure this
out or are you gonna be a statistic mom
and this is something that she didn't
sit down and tell me I realized this
this is the world that is in front of me
and what most people do is they see this
world and they look at it as an excuse
to get out of it
you know I started looking at it as this
is the ultimate training ground for the
rest of my life mm-hmm I have all these
valuable lessons because if you look at
the world right now today it's not a
nice place I'm very prepared for it yeah
you are
I've been prepared for it I'm prepared
for all the failure coming my way I'm
prepared for everything my way and
that's the biggest lesson that she
taught me by not teaching me mm-hmm
by never saying it's gonna be okay
I'm a fact she told me exact opposite Y
sucks so why do we make so many excuses
I think that we are like excuses making
machine it's like if I miss a deal we do
a lot of real estate deals so if I miss
a deal I'm always going to what did I do
wrong in that deal first response for me
is what did I do wrong in that deal then
they didn't pick me mm-hmm what did I do
wrong that I didn't get that deal what
did we do wrong that we didn't hit our
number they're like I'm never saying
it's not blaming somebody well I don't
have control when I blame I want control
so even if they are to blame right I
want control I'm not gonna assign you
blame if you hit my car I'm gonna get my
said what did I do wrong what did I do
that allowed you to hit my car hmm I did
something so even in the most dumb dumb
like III ended up in a lawsuit where a
guy basically found something sued me
for it I didn't do anything to this dude
my immediate response was what did I do
to create that frivolous situation he
was a criminal total criminal sued me
for 60 million bucks he just sued me
because he he thought he could get
something wrong again but but I did
something and the reason I want to
assume that what the cause I want to be
the cause point is because if I assume
that position even though I didn't
really do anything then I can control
what I did
I can't control what another person does
but I can spend time and energy control
them what I do
I've been evangelizing one particular
message
two decades and that you can lead
without a title you know the seduction
of society is that you have to have
formal power to make a difference and
that's just a lie the world has sold us
the reality is you can lead without a
title and really the difference or the
defining trait of a leader is you shift
from victimhood see victims love making
excuses and if you recite your excuses
long enough you actually think they're
gonna be true I see it around the world
you know people saying these things like
I don't have time to run or I don't I'm
not good enough to be great of my work
or this would never work or I don't live
in the right country or a life is hard
and the more you recite those excuses
you think they're true so let go of your
excuses start getting some results done
and over time you're gonna rise to your
world-class tuck this for a second
because this just blew my mind is your
dad that come from India right yes all
right mm-hmm
and your dad you're in the cab you just
get here you're interested yep and my
mom's already here okay so I bless her
self as a nurse and well my dad it was
easier for my it was easier for my mom
to get her license here and as a nurse
practitioner that was for my dad to get
his license as a doctor all right an MD
mmm and he wasn't able to get it wasn't
able to get the license we still came
over we were sitting in the cab and he's
counted the money and the meter gets to
I forget what the number was and my dad
tells the cab driver stop and you're a
little boy boy I was four years old I
said stop and we're like what's going on
mmm and my dad goes hey listen we're in
a new country I want you to enjoy the
scenery so we get out grab all the
luggage she's awesome
hmm and we're walking down the street
[Music]
mm-hm it's a hustle [ __ ] you got it no
walking down the street with his luggage
hmm and it's showing us a different
scenery and so forth hmm never knew he
didn't have any more money in this
pocket Wow Wow
amazing but he got it got you there
that's powerful you imagined that little
boy walking down that Street turns out
to be you then amazing yes so in those
scenes into you and there's moments like
that that define you as long as you
remember they can define you both ways
you can look at it and say you know what
you can use that as an excuse my dad
came to this country he didn't have any
money he never gave me anything he never
did this and people do that not even
look at and say he gave us everything
successful people don't make excuses
successful people don't complain if you
look at whoever you want to look up to
look at the most successful people in
the world in any industry look at the
top and look at how much they complain
they don't complain when you complain
when you blame something else when it's
the government's fault or interest rates
fault or the bad economies fault or your
partner who screwed you over or the
customers who don't care as long as you
can blame somebody else right the
education system your parents your
friends your upbringing there's always
somebody else to blame and when you
blame somebody else when you're in that
mindset then you never grow you make it
things easy on yourself it allows you to
Coast it allows you to play live super
safe because it's not your fault that
you're not more successful of course
it's not your fault that would be
difficult that would be hard it's
somebody else's fault so you can just
stay where you are because people are
holding you back from accomplishing the
thing that you want to come to you we're
successful people take responsibility
for where they are in life and they say
I don't care about the government I
don't care who's president I don't care
about regulations that you have or
things that you're holding me back on I
will still go out and get mine
and of course there are other factors of
course the country you come from matters
of course education you have any and the
connections you had growing up of course
it matters but so what you have to play
the hand that you are doubt you have
these cards you have to play those cards
and you can have success one of the
things I love looking at and this is why
I do all these profiles is successful
famous entrepreneurs there is always
somebody who has done way more than you
have done with way fewer resources than
you already have
so no matter what terrible situation
that you have an empathetic maybe you
have count of a broken home maybe we
have a really severe disability that's
physically holding you back from doing
some of the things you want to do you
know maybe there's a lot of pressure on
you maybe you have some disease maybe
you have zero money in your bank account
these are real pressures and on
empathetic to that but so what the
longer you believe that those things are
gonna hold you where you are then they
will there are people who have worse
conditions less money are in worse
situations and they came out of it and
accomplished amazing things because they
believed that they could and if somebody
looks like you has gone on accomplish
big things then you can too and it only
happens when you accept responsibility
for where you are in life there was
another thing you said that I thought
was really powerful about how insights
themselves are essentially inert they
don't do anything what what then do we
do with an insight how do we take a
breakthrough moment and make sure that
it's not just a breakthrough moment like
I guaranteed people watching right now
or having like a hundred aha moments for
sure that was definitely the case for me
as I was researching you and when you
said that and I was like and that's the
danger that you have the AHA and then
nothing yeah yeah and that's it's a it
is a danger because then people will
will shrink back into mediocracy
and they'll use the insight to excuse
them from taking a leap they'll say yeah
you know I have a chemical imbalance in
my brain my father was really
overbearing he was a perfectionist
that's why I am the way and you know
people they
come up with stuff to to excuse
themselves the insight is actually
giving them permission to stay limited
and it's an amazing idea because they'll
say to you and they really want to get
over their anxiety but let's okay let's
take your ex-husband let's put them in a
straitjacket let's duct tape them and
shoot them to the moon now what I mean
what are you gonna do now you still have
to make those changes and sew them the
person's enemy dies or their something
shifts in their life and that person's
gone they'll find another person to hate
this is just how we function as human
beings we just slide another reason to
feel those emotions so I think I think
when people start to understand this you
know I think knowledge is power but
knowledge about yourself is
self-empowerment
point number nine you're an expert at
making excuses literally everything that
happens in your life you got a great
excuse for it everything I couldn't show
up it was raining I was sick I had a flu
my dog was sick my mom wasn't in a good
mood such-and-such happen you know this
is what happened my leg I was cramping I
had a hard workout you don't understand
my favorite team is playing excuse girl
or for everything if you have that money
is just not attracted to excuses just
kind of how this thing works if I have a
bunch of things order that are important
to me then I'm gonna make time for all
those things and I don't think that it's
a good excuse to say that like there's
not enough time in the day because there
is there's 24 hours of it so I think
that if you have the drive to do all the
things you want to do then you
definitely can like I've had days where
I go to school and then I have away
games for volleyball and I leave from
the volleyball game get dressed in the
car and go to a like event for something
and then go home and do homework and
then wake up the next day and go to
school so I like have never really given
myself the excuse that like I only have
time for certain things because I don't
think you know you can do all the things
you love if you want to so yeah just
like plan your time well
now I've got a really special bonus clip
from Zlatan Ibrahimovic on how to make
no excuses that I think you're gonna
enjoy but before that some of the
three-point landing questions time to
move from just watching another video to
actually taking action in your life or
your business and if you're feeling bold
leave your answers in the comments below
here we go question number one what
excuses do you need to let go of number
two how will you catch yourself the next
time that excuse shows up and number
three who can hold you accountable to
following through
the pictures believing you were a lion
is that right I am a loyal you are a
line
are there enough lines around you in
this team hey listen I will be honest to
myself the table is not lying I think
the team is where it is because it is
what it is if we would be number one we
would be number one top four for me it's
last time I came second I don't even
remember that was in midland AC bella AC
Milan and people like that no you said
it was something you weren't used to
that was the first position of the last
ones for that I don't really like and
then describe that season as a failure
it is a failure
so this whatever happened whatever comes
after the first one is a failure the
most important work ever if you had to
think of one word that's most important
to you or that sums you Apple
that would be like a little beacon if
you want to know what's stopping you
from achieving success check out the
video right there next to me I think
you'll enjoy it continue to believe and
I'll see you there dr. Wayne Dyer houses
as the famous phrase where it's not oh
I'll believe it when I see it it's like
I'll see it when I believe it